[Music]
when the villain in a movie is nicknamed
the god butcher it's safe to assume that
not everyone is going to make it out
alive so who gets it in thor love and
thunder keep watching to find out
oh god we're going to die
taika ytt is a master at blending absurd
comedy with emotional storytelling
especially when it comes to kids and
their parental figures thor love and
thunder eventually fits that mold but it
starts off on a note that's completely
humorless unexpectedly dark and almost
too tragic to be believed in what was
advertised as a zany mcu movie gore and
his daughter whose name we don't know
are seeking shelter from destructive
sandstorms and looking for even so much
as a drop of water despite gore's
prayers their planet has become
uninhabitable and their civilization has
been lost the girl doodles on rocks
while gore prays to his god rapu some
time passes we don't know how much and
gore holds his child in his arms as
she's dying of thirst she tells him that
she's tired before she passes away in
front of his eyes he buries her on his
home planet and decorates her grave with
rocks though the audience surely went in
anticipating that they'd be rooting
against gore the scene is played with
such devastating realism you can't help
but mourn for the little girl and
sympathize with her father who becomes
the god butcher because of this seismic
loss oh god she will die
it's a sad irony that gore spots an
oasis only after his dear daughter's
death as he stumbles over to the
tree-lined watering hole he can't quite
tell if what lies before him is real or
an illusion he collapses into the water
then notices something rustling behind
all the greenery it's rapu played by
ytt's what we do in the shadow's co-star
jonathan bruff the god to whom gore had
been praying decked out in gold with an
ostentatious headpiece gore assumes rapu
is welcoming him into the afterlife he
shows rapu the pendant he wears around
his neck to mark himself as one of his
followers but rapu isn't there to save
anybody he's chilling with the flower
gods and has long been entirely
indifferent to gore's people's suffering
rapu's main concern is the existence of
the necrosaur a weapon that can kill
gods at a price and that conveniently
now rests near gore's right hand when
gore tells rapu that his kingdom is
fallen the god shrugs it off and says
there will always be new souls to
worship him he breaks the bad news to
his last remaining devotee there is no
eternal reward that enrages an already
spiritually broken gore who rips the
religious pendant from his neck and is
suddenly able to wield the levitating
necrosword he uses it to stab a taken
aback rapoo in the throat and it's
implied he decapitates him to finish the
job
after he becomes aware of gore the god
butcher thor discovers distressed
signals from all across the universe in
one he sees lady sith gravely injured
thor and korg make haste to try and
rescue his fellow asgardian warrior but
when they arrive they're not so
pleasantly greeted by the mountain-sized
corpse of a frost-covered creature korg
asks who or what it is and he clearly
shaken thor replies that this is falagar
one of the nicest gods anybody could
ever hope to meet valagar appeared in
the promotional material for thor love
and thunder and it intrigued comic book
fans as it's a pretty precise recreation
of a panel from thor god of thunder
volume one number three though the film
doesn't get into much detail about
falliger or his relationship with thor
at all both use him in much the same way
on the page falagar is an old friend of
thor's who rules over the galactic
frontier and enjoys sparring even
against black holes after some years
apart from each other thor learns that
falagar is dead at the hands of gore the
godbutcher thor's line to korg suggests
they had a similar friendship in the mcu
and here too he meets his end because of
gore's vow to wipe out all the gods
though his enormous lifeless body makes
for a breathtaking shot it's a shame we
didn't get to see this peculiar majestic
god in action
thor and mighty thor team up to
successfully destroy the necrosword but
they don't do it quick enough to stop
gore the godbutcher from using
stormbreaker to open the gate to
eternity as gore walks through the
circular door into eternity's realm and
stands before the powerful living cosmic
entity represented as a galactic
silhouette thor tells him that he's one
meanwhile jane who used her last ounce
of strength as mighty thor to wield
mjolnir against the necrosword falls to
the watery ground as a cancer patient
once again she and thor have a final
conversation that moves him and changes
his plan gore comes to realize that with
his one wish to eternity he could bring
back his daughter rather than
exterminate the gods however the necro
sword corrupted his own body so much he
knows that like jane he's about to die
too even though he won't be around to
see the ramifications of his choice he
decides to give his daughter another
chance at life rather than fulfill his
vow of vengeance jane promises that she
won't be alone and gore lives just long
enough to say goodbye to his resurrected
child and to ask thor to promise to
protect her in the scene that follows we
see thor has adopted her and is raising
her to be an asgardian warrior like him
and that gore redeemed himself in thor's
eyes by choosing love instead of hate
early on in thor love and thunder we
learn that jane's been diagnosed with
stage four cancer and it isn't
responding to treatment while in her
office she flips through an old book of
norse mythology and notices the word
mjolnir feeling called to her former
boyfriend's former weapon she travels to
new asgard incognito and tries to summon
the hammer we learn from a montage of
their relationship that thor once
ordered mjolnir to protect jane his true
love this produced powerful magic that
bound the hammer to jane and for a while
jane in the audience think that magic is
healing her as it gives her superhuman
strength let's bring the rainbow but
when she lands back in the hospital
worse for the wear every time she suits
up as mighty thor she figures out what's
really going on mjolnir is actually
using up her remaining life force once
jane comes clean to thor about her
condition he begs her not to pick up the
hammer again and tells her that he loves
her he hopes that they can find a cure
and still have a chance at a life
together once he returns from facing
gore alone jane understands his request
but she knows there's likely no cure she
joins her love for one last classic thor
adventure and with her dying breaths
tells him that she's content that she
lived an extraordinary albeit short life
for a human they end their relationship
on sad but good terms as she vanishes
the end credits scene reveals that since
she died of viking on the battlefield
she's welcomed into valhalla by none
other than heimdall
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
thor love and thunder are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]